I feel after going out in public and
getting zero compliments zero people
approaching me zero people asking me for
my number when this is a known thing for
girls to experience y'all I canot relate
more like I swear not even the
construction workers want me like I
could walk in New York buy a
construction site nobody would say
anything I know this isn't something
that you should want but after a while
it's like damn yeah yeah that's what I
said women will never appreciate what we
have until it's gone and we're getting
more antisocial and the men are just
thinking this is too much work I I don't
I don't want these chicks to start
crying about it later